lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar la idea de frecuencia alélica
déjame notarlo aquí frecuencia
cuencia
al el ica
a la liga y al él y acá habla de la idea
de alelos sólo como recordatorio un
alelo es la variante de un gen tú tienes
una variante de un gen de tu madre y
obtienes otra o la misma variante del
gen de tu padre entonces cuando hablamos
de un alelo estamos hablando de la
variante específica que obtuviste de tu
madre o de tu padre y ya vimos esto
antes recuerdas
pero ahora excavaremos un poco más
profundo para entender un poco mejor
esta idea y para eso empezaremos con un
modelo bastante común pensemos en el
color de los ojos obviamente esto es una
gran simplificación pero supongamos que
tenemos una población donde hay sólo dos
variantes del gen que determina el color
de los ojos bueno primero supongamos que
hay un gen que determina el color de los
ojos y después supongamos que hay dos
variantes un alelo del color de ojo que
voy a poner con las letras
ve en mayúscula va a ser la letra que me
representa el alelo de los ojos cafés
ojos
y vamos a suponer que este es un alelo
dominante déjame ponerlo así de mí
mientras que por otra parte voy a pensar
también en b minúscula como aquella
letra que va a representar el alelo de
los ojos azules
sus
y por cierto es un alelo recesivo
recesivo sí
otra vez esto es un repaso cuando una de
las personas tiene uno de los alelos b
mayúscula el alelo café entonces bueno
no va a importar cuál sea el otro alelo
si es el de ojos cafés o es el de ojos
azules porque la persona va a tener ojos
cafés esto nos dará ojos cafés es decir
que esto nos dará ojos cafés y bueno
también esto nos va a dar ojos cafés
porque la ve minúscula es dominante la
única manera de tener ojos azules es
tener el homo cigoto be minúscula be
minúscula el homo cigoto para el alelo
recesivo y todo esto claro es un repaso
porque ya lo vimos antes pero ahora
pensemos en la frecuencia alélica déjame
quitar esto de aquí y a partir de ahora
de lo que quiero hablar es sobre la idea
de plantear una pequeña población
artificial digamos que en nuestra
población artificial tiene solamente dos
personas así que las voy a poner por
aquí
esta es una de ellas y esta es otra de
ellas así que a esta le voy a poner
persona 1 a esta le voy a poner persona
2 e imagina que somos capaces de ver su
adn y así de conocer sus genotipos
entonces la persona 1 voy a suponer que
tiene el alelo b mayúscula y además
tiene el otro le lo ve en minúscula b
minúscula es decir tiene un alelo café y
uno azul mientras que voy a decir que la
persona 2 tiene 2 alelos azules así que
aquí están mis dos ale los azules
ahora bien debido a que sabemos los
genotipos de esta pequeña población
artificial ya podemos pensar en las
frecuencias alélicas o en las
frecuencias de los distintos alelos es
lo mismo entonces cuál crees que vaya a
ser la frecuencia para la ley lo café de
esta población
la frecuencia paralelo café de esta
población y te invito a que pausa el
vídeo y pienses acerca de esto por tu
cuenta
suponiendo que ya lo hiciste vamos a
resolverlo a lo mejor estuviste tentado
es decir parece ser que una de las dos
personas tiene el alelo y por lo tanto
esta frecuencia es del 50% pero esa no
es la manera adecuada cuando hablamos de
frecuencias alélicas en frecuencias
alélicas tienes que excavar un poco más
y ver los alelos individuales cuando los
ves puedes decir que hay cuatro alelos
individuales uno dos tres cuatro o bien
cuatro variantes o incluso puedes decir
que hay cuatro cromosomas por eso aquí
abajo voy a poner un 4 mientras que sólo
uno de ellos es el alelo de la d
mayúscula entonces aquí voy a poner un 1
es por eso que podemos decir que su
frecuencia es lo mismo que un cuarto o
0.25 o también lo podemos ver como el
25% estás de acuerdo el 25% de los genes
para el color de ojos tiene como alelo b
mayúscula tiene
el café bueno y si ahora nos queremos
preguntar lo mismo para la ley de
minúscula cuál es la frecuencia de
minúscula cuál va a ser nuestra
respuesta y de nuevo te invito a que
pausas el vídeo y lo intente resolver
por ti mismo bueno me vas a decir que ya
es muy sencillo porque entonces acá
abajo voy a poner un 4 porque tenemos 4
alelos distintos uno dos tres cuatro y
de estos cuatro tenemos uno dos tres ale
los que tienen la b en minúscula así que
voy a poner aquí un 3 entonces podemos
decir que su frecuencia es lo mismo que
0.75 o dicho de otra manera el 75% es
decir que el 75% de los genes para el
color de ojos tiene el alelo b en
minúscula o el alelo azul mientras que
el 25% tiene el alelo b mayúscula o el
alelo café y quiero dejar este punto
bastante claro y que observes que esto
es distinto de hablar
la frecuencia del fenotipo si te
pregunto en esta población cuál es el
porcentaje de personas con los ojos
cafés antes de ponerlo aquí cuál es el
porcentaje de
personas personas con ojos de color café
con ojos cafés bueno tú me vas a decir
que en este caso tenemos dos personas
una dos personas ahora estamos hablando
del fenotipo y entonces una de ellas
está exhibiendo ojos cafés por lo tanto
este porcentaje va a ser lo mismo que
uno
de la misma manera si me preguntaran
cuál es el porcentaje de personas con
ojos azules bueno también sería un medio
este de aquí esta persona es una de las
dos personas y esta exhibe ojos azules
pero cuando hablamos de frecuencia
alélica estamos excavando más profundo
estamos viendo los genotipos es decir
estamos diciendo que uno de los cuatro
genes es el alelo b en mayúscula y esto
es el 25 por ciento de los genes de esta
población que codifican para ojos color
café y el 75% codifica para los ojos de
color azul y es muy importante analizar
todo esto porque una vez que lo
entendamos veremos la idea del modelo de
hardy vancouver y veremos que este
modelo tiene mucho sentido y es más te
voy a dar un pequeño adelanto podemos
denotar a este de aquí como se me ocurre
ponerle en minúscula p minúscula ya este
de aquí lo voy a denotar como con
minúscula así que déjame tomar el color
correspondiente y voy a poner aquí
y va a ser este eje es decir p minúscula
va a representar la frecuencia del alelo
dominante y con minúscula va a
representar la frecuencia del alelo
recesivo y bueno con todo esto amplia me
podrás decir cuánto va a valer temas
como déjame ponerlo aquí cuánto va a ser
p con este color más q con este otro
color cuánto será la suma de estos dos y
de nuevo te invito a que pases el vídeo
y lo pienses un poco esto es p mas q ya
cuánto va a ser igual bueno cuando
empezamos este vídeo hicimos la
suposición de que sólo había dos alelos
para este gen en los rasgos de esta
población
entonces la frecuencia de los alelos
dominantes más la frecuencia de los
alelos recesivos sólo será la suma de
estos dos alelos y será el cien por
ciento por lo tanto puedo decir que 25%
más 75% esto me va a dar un 100 por
ciento o también lo puedo ver de la
siguiente manera como
más
dónde está el color justo aquí más q
esto va a ser igual am y lo puedo ver
como la suma de punto 25.75 lo cual me
va a dar 1 en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
partir de esta idea que es bastante
bastante sencilla para ver una idea más
amplia y clara que está expresada en la
ecuación de hardy mainfer